Michael Scott, This is Holly.
Can I kiss you? Yeah.
Okay.
Hey, Michael.
Oh, hey. Do you still work here?
I'd like to introduce you to my replacement.
Nah, come on. No, I.
Think I will pass.
Michael Scott, this is Holly.
Hi.
Hi. Yeah, right.
Okay, well, they hired a female Toby.
Good for the world. Thank you, God, for
creating two of you.
Here's how things work here.
My job is to make the office fun.
Your job is to make the office lame.
And we have an eternal struggle, you and I.
And only one of us can be the winner.
Spoiler alert. I'm going to win.
Man Someone doesn't like H.R.
Yeah. What did you do to him?
Nothing.
No, he tortured me with his awfulness.
Yeah, I know what you mean.
I nearly fell asleep when he gave me a tour
of the files.
Well, look, I'll let you get back to work,
but I really look forward to working with
you, Mr. Scott.
Thank you, Michael.
Hello, Holly.
Whoa. What are you doing?
You don't. You don't have to do that.
I mean, we have already put together chairs.
That's how we buy them, actually.
Oh, I'm trying to adjust the lumbar support
on Toby's chair.
And that made this up down lever thing, not
work. And then I took the whole chair apart.
And that is the story of me on the floor.
It's pretty good, right?
I'm going to sell the movie rights.
And the sequel woman stands at desk and
works. Yeah.
So I have no idea how you.
How you sit like that.
Yoga, Sit on floor and put together chair.
We will. Yoda.
Pass curvy metal piece.
You will.
So are you in town this weekend?
Because I'm not.
I'm not. I'm not going to be in town going
out of town.
Oh, so you can't make my orgy?
Kidding.
Kidding. Acting.
Acting.
Love it.
Yeah.
Hey there. Hey.
So you missed something really big?
Yeah. Yeah. Andy proposed to one of your
accountants. Oh, wow.
I mean, that's a specific as I can be on my
first day.
Well, I can see Andy proposing to Angela.
I can also see him proposing to Oscar.
Okay.
So, you know, somehow.
After all those ribs, I'm still really
hungry. I know.
I was thinking of maybe going off campus
somewhere and getting some dessert.
Oh.
Well, you know what?
You should go to the glider diner.
Ask Stanley about that.
Practically lives there.
Okay. I'll go to the diner with you.
Oh, that would be great.
We can go eat pie.
I love pie.
Me too. Okay.
Have a good night. Okay.
All right. I can't believe I'm saying this,
but Michael is actually killing it with
Holly, and I think I know why.
It's because Holly is kind of a major dork.
I'm MC Mike Scott and
I am hot.
She's DJ Jazzy Flax, and she is the best.
All those sucker branches can suck our fat.
Wicka-wicka-wicka-what!
We should have a party and not invite them.
Yeah. Let's go. Mini golfing.
Yeah.
Oh, hey, can I have a rain check on the mini
golf? I actually have a date tonight.
Oh. Probably be a total disaster.
But I think you'll have fun because men from
Scranton are handsome and they know how to
show a woman a good time.
Not that guy who
murdered his mother, he was not so handsome.
Also, Kevin, you know what?
We're pretty much done here today.
Why don't you just take off early?
Really? Yeah.
Oh, that's sweet. Wish me luck.
Good luck. Wow.
Holly doesn't need luck.
Everyone that meets her instantly loves her.
Want to go out.
Yes.
I didn't feel much when I held Astrid, but I
got a good feeling from Holly.
It's time to go.
No, no.
Reservations are date. So we've got, like, an
hour and 45 minutes.
I'm a crazy eight. I'm crazy.
You're crazy. Go crazy.
Oh, I forgot my keys.
Do you need them? Yeah.
Let's go grab them. All right.
Oh, after vou.
Thank you.
Why? Oh.
I didn't forget my keys.
I just didn't want to make out with you in
front of the cameras.
Do you think they can hear us?
Not if we turn these dials all the way down.
Now they can't hear us at all.
Oh, good.
We're totally alone.
What's the matter.
Oh, it's.. It's not going to work.
There's too much distance.
No, no, no, no.
It's going to work. It'll be
fine. Michael, we've only been dating each
other for a few weeks. Listen to
me. I like you so much.
I like you, too. And I've dated almost four
women. I've dated
four guys last year too.
Not know in, like, the last ten years, I've
dated almost four women.
And you are so far above them.
It is stupid.
Michael.
Don't. Don't make it harder than it has to
be.
Holly thinks that this relationship is over.
Well, you know what?
I am not going to give up that easy.
I'm going to make this way harder than it
needs to be.
It's the last of it.
Oh, that's mine, actually.
Maybe put it back in the truck.
You're not staying.
You know, I have some things I need to do
this weekend. I just remembered.
So. I'll just ride back with you.
But, you want me to put it back
in the truck? I'll be down in just a second.
Holly. So.
I think I'm going to go back with Daryl.
Okay. Bye.
Okay, bye.
It was hard, Mike. Breakups hurt?
We didn't break up. Looked like it.
January 3, 2011, a day which will live in
famously.
Holly Partridge Flax, otherwise known as
Holly, otherwise otherwise known as a
living, breathing angel, is engaged to
another man. This is freaking me out.
I. Okay, let's just switch to the happy
video. Okay. No, no, no, no.
Let's push through. We'll do this today.
We'll either be the best or the worst day of
my life. Holly gave AJ an ultimatum.
He either proposes by New Year's or they
break up. Now, if she's engaged, I'm going
to go crazy and I'm going to start attacking
people if she's not engaged.
In all honesty, I may just burn this whole
place to the ground out of happiness.
Hello?
What happened? Is there a ring?
So high five me.
We're back to a happy.
Look at
those mittens.
Those a present?
Those are- Those are so fuzzy and warm.
Let me feel those. Let me feel that.
Put her there. Give me a good firm one.
Oh, that's a good, firm handshake.
You're hired.
Yes. Well, let's get right into the Anderson
account, shall we?
Okay. Okay.
Yes. Yes, Right away.
Okay. Hey, hey, hey.
Let me crank the thermostat to 90.
Smoke her out. She can't keep those mittens
on forever. Yes.
No.
What? Stop! Yes.
Congratulations. Wow.
Oh, my God. That's it.
That's it.
Oh, I get it.
Everybody knows about the ultimatum.
Yes, I told everyone.
Ha ha.
Ha ha. Hey.
Right back at you, b*tch.
My resolution.
I never want to make Holly cry again unless
it's from laughing too hard or making love
too beautifully.
We're going to be just fine.
You know how you say something over and over
in the words start to sound weird?
Going to be just fine.
Just fine.
I just think we need to cool things down for
a while. Yeah.
A break.
At least until I get back to Nashua.
Michael.
Hi. How did you know I was up here?
What are you doing up here?
I got turned around.
I thought I could see Dunder.
Dunder Mifflin.
Yeah, I know.
I just miss you so much.
I missed you too.
Really?
Yeah.
Can I kiss you?
Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Bye bye.
Oh, miss.
You. Miss you.
Okay. I'll be in my office if you need me.
Bye.
Okay. Bye. All right.
One more big.
One. No go. I don't want.
I don't want to go. Don't go.
Holly and I are dating.
It's been a week and I still can't believe
it. It goes to show that everything you want
in life you get and you can't work for it.
It just comes to you.
Okay. Sit.
Okay. Just close your eyes.
Can you get lower?
Oh, yeah, a little lower.
I cannot keep myself from Michael.
Everything he does is sexy.
He has this undeniable animal magnetism.
He's a jungle cat.
The man exudes sex.
He can put both his legs behind his head.
Thank you all for meeting on such short
notice. Yes.
Yes. Michael Scott.
Dunder Mifflin. What is the purpose of this
meeting?
Seeing as it's Valentine's Day, I felt it
would be apropos to have a little refresher
course on romance in the workplace.
Perfect.
Yes, it is quite appropriate.
Carry on.
First things first. An office romance is
permissible. Not something you'd expect to
hear from corporate. Well, guess what?
Sabre is 100% tolerant of office romances.
Hi, guys.
This is where our love faces its toughest
test. After this, it's just smooth sailing
for the rest of our lives.
Holly, will you marry me?
No.
Marry me, Holly.
That guy's got more than he can handle as it
is.
Will you marry me?
No. That marriage would be a sham.
You marry me?
No.
Easy. No.
Will you marry me? No.
That would be hot. I would pay to see that.
Will you marry me, Holly?
No. Only one that I was kind of worried
about.
Oh. This is where I fell in love with you.
And this is where I ask you to marry me.
It started with the.
Ha ha.
Holly Flax. Marrying me.
Will you be?
Your wife
becoming me, will I?
Woo! Guys this is so awesome.
Congratulations. Congratulations.
Thank you.